drawn-out Rainbow six siege is entering
year three with two new attackers lion
and finca before chimera siege had
become a game about attacker stepping
lightly and defenders rolling deep in
defense of advantages you had frost
maths Ella Griz MOT mines lesions mines
mirrors Peep Show and caviar a savage
power stance all of this made aggressive
attackers fear for their shins and gave
the green light to aggressive roaming on
defense this all felt like it was
getting away from the original idea of
siege that attackers and defenders are
meant to play rounds differently
chimera looks to write that balance with
lions new freeze dance ability
because when attackers say freeze you
better freeze
[Music]
this Lions new e1d drone is a sizeable
thing that can be seen hovering over
most maps when he's on the field it can
be activated three times around with
fairly minimal cooldown defenders get a
warning they're about to be scanned and
then anyone not standing still or
sitting on top of a mute jammer gets
revealed to the entire attacking team
this means attackers can time their
assaults to the use of this gadget
ideally forcing defenders to move and be
easily picked off to be fair it's a
double-edged sword good defensive teams
can find places to hole up and make
attackers overconfident overall this
ability brings the meta back in line
with attackers advancing and defenders
preparing spaces for advantage side note
it can also be very useful if attackers
haven't found objective sites and need
to know where the enemy team is at in
our session we had some good
back-and-forth on the attack once
defenders learn not to move it became a
game of making them move using some
classic approaches such as fuses mines
shooting through walls or aggressive
maneuvering we did test other defensive
counters including trying to shoot down
the drone outside with both attack and
defense pecans we tried vigils ability
to evade detection doesn't work and
tried being to choke on his turret
surrounded by mute jammers like a bronze
god that worked until we got shot so to
recap the only thing that keeps
defenders from being seen is holding
still or putting your butt on a mute
jammer if your entire defensive team
stands still Hawaiian's abilities over
in just a few seconds and it's back to
business as usual
[Music]
to help the attacking team with
aggressive moves and to counter some
defensive traps that do damage over time
think it joins the game with her adrenal
surge which she can put to use three
times around her ability gives a brief
HP boost and can revive any ally on the
entire map in a Down panada of state we
experimented with a revive ability and
found it to be much faster than other
methods at the cost of hit points
regained in our tests a player
classically reviving another player
restored 50 hit points players are
taking advantage of this with the reset
tactic these days a doc shot will get a
player 275 hit points but fincas team
revive only gets players 225 just to
reiterate though she can quickly revive
all down players with the press of a
button on any part of the map all at
once thank you she can't however revive
herself from a Down State in the same
way as dr. Sofia when you put line and
finger together they make attackers
faster and more confident in their
ability to fight to the objective on
time on the defending side there's a lot
of people yelling each other not to move
and setting up more thoughtful defenses
which makes the game better in my
opinion we successfully ran some classic
Dee such as fighting from the outside in
on kids bedroom on house nice I didn't
have enough time to fully explore new
weapons which fell in line with French
and Russian operators but let's do a
quick rundown line gets the V 308 a
vector with 50 rounds the 417 semi-auto
marksman rifle the SG CQB shotgun and p9
pistol or LFP 586 revolver finca gets
the spear 308 bullpup prototype which
has good kick the 6p 41 LMG similar
defuse the SAS G 12 semi-auto shotgun
and PM m and G SH 18 pistols now it's
interesting I get a lot of mixed answers
from players about the speed of Rainbow
six siege think it in line or both to
speed to Armour but I can't help feeling
like that doesn't matter with siege
being so much about headshots so do you
prefer a faster or slower more planned
out game does lions wall hack look good
to you or maybe a little too good let's
talk about it in the comments below and
make sure to stay tuned for our upcoming
videos on the new outbreak mode thanks
for watching
[Music]